a lot to get to, but quickly today's episode
of hatred mail.
Quick reminder.
What is hatred?
Male,
because thoughts and prayers are bullet
approve Patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and because
freedom.
All right and needing absolutely no introduction.
Here is this week's Patriot mail with a very
specific conspiracy theory about what is happening
on our program.
How can you subscribers to this PAC man's
channel, not see how completely fake he is.
The callers are all acting.
They are plans.
Those are the average people off the street.
Just calling in.
Do you really think for one second that the
man Pac-Man just talked to actually listens
to the Pacman show to even know the number
to call in.
This is all fake people.
Stop giving your money to the sleazy beta
male since he says he always goes to the sores.
It was only a matter of time, right until
we became the subject of the conspiracy theories
and it has happened.
The callers are just random people.
Uh, we have caller ID if someone calls in
once we put their name into the system.
So if they call again, I know when they are
calling, but that is all that is going on
with the callers.
They are not planted actors.
There is no conspiracy to make a conservative
sound dumb or anything else.
That is it.
Remember you can fight hatred, autism by using
the coupon code hatred@fortywhenyousignupforamembershipatjoinpacman.com
the coupon code hatred 40 will save you 40%
and it is like a middle finger to the hatred.
It's I recommend using it.
Why not?